look at the emotion of shanaine Flanagan
as she comes to the line breaks the tape
Shalin Lanigan won the New York City
Marathon last year she became the first
American woman to achieve that feat in
decades inspiring other American women
to follow in her footsteps Flanagan is a
four-time Olympian and a former
collegiate cross country champion and
now she's an author for the second time
she co-wrote the cookbook run fast cook
fast eat slow we recently laced up our
sneakers and ran some questions by her
do you have a mantra that you say in
your head to yourself yes and no you
know each one changes for each marathon
that I'm running and you know when after
the Boston Marathon bombings it was run
for those who can't or for this year in
New York when chalene Flanagan won the
New York City Marathon last November she
punctuated the moment with the grit and
swagger befitting of the streets she
just conquered yes from my parents 100%
yeah my dad was like what we don't use
that language and the next moment I know
eats cursing so as an expression yeah
I've got this yeah it was you can't take
this away from me this is my moment a
history-making moment as Flanagan at the
age of 36 became the first American
woman in 40 years to break the tape in
New York
this summer she announced she's coming
back for more you're back in New York
it's a magical city for me how so every
time I come here I swear like the hairs
on my arms stand up I just feel like
this magical sense it like incites this
excitement in me and this passion for
running so I just felt like I had to
come back do you think you're born an
elite runner I always say you make
yourself a marathoner or a runner I
think you put in the work you run the
race the clock tells you exactly how
good you are you put in the work and
you're rewarded those rewards are
hard-earned and they required a
concentration on diet we grew up in a
culture at least in college back at
Carolina you know that that would make
you fat so we were eating everything
low-fat and little do we know that we
were
eating more sugar and processed foods
with the help of her best friend
nutritionist and chef Elise Kopecky
Flanagan has replaced processed foods
with healthy fats the Thai quinoa salad
is one of my favorites which is great
because it you can make a huge batch and
I can have it for multiple meals either
at lunch or dinner you're 37 I mean do
you think the way you changed your diet
has prolonged your career I genuinely
believe the way Elise has taught me to
incorporate healthy fats and just a
wholesome diet has really extended my
career I don't think I'd be sitting here
talking to you and running at a high
level if it weren't for the fact that I
changed my diet Flanagan says she hopes
her cookbook can help fellow runners
because while marathon training is a
solitary sport
he says it's helping other athletes
especially women that is most rewarding
I heard that after you won New York City
last year that you actually came back
later at night to greet runners who were
coming across the finish line honestly
coming back to the finish line
nearly six seven eight hours later and
people are still out there running and
just seeing their reaction to seeing all
of us there to celebrate their
achievement it really made my day how
does that make you feel to know that
there's so many women who admire you
want to be like you
I mean you're growing the sport that is
maybe you know the greatest compliment
and thankfully the greatest contribution
I think I've made you know winning is
great but I think having a positive
effect around you the circle and how you
affect people it's great to be a great
runner but it's more important to be a
good person for sure because if I
elevate them it's gonna elevate me boy
and she is elevating this sport she's
elevating American women marathon
runners we thought des linden won in
Boston this year and she's back for more
at 37 and what I marvel nor is it you
keep up with her we should should know
Nora is actually a runner too but you
kept up with her and that you guys can
talk and run at the same time yeah that
was like probably for half a mile though
I think
yeah I would have liked nice I love that
line elevate them and elevates me and
you can hear more excuse this morning on
our podcast available on Apple's podcast
app or wherever you download your
podcasts you're watching CBS this
morning